well dozens of regular unemployment
claimants have reached out to eight news
now but
issues filing this week's claim many say
they're missing a link to do so on their
portal
joe muller is live outside the las vegas
deter office with what he's learned
about this issue
joe well i've been told by a detailed
representative that they know there is a
problem that people are having issues
trying to file their weekly claims and
they are working to address it now
there's a number of problems that people
are running into there's two of them
that
stand out in one instance claimants
cannot see the link to file the claim
the other problem is the link when you
when it's clicked
another page pops up that says error
currently the staff is working to
correct the issues
with no defined time frame when these
issues will be resolved that's according
to dieter
a representative says claimants are
encouraged to clear their cookies and
revisit the site
now when issues like this pop up many
claimants reach out to us because as you
can imagine people are worried about not
getting paid including kathy solomon
i can make most of my bills
but then i have no money for food that's
what this money goes for
and so i need the money
and peter sits there and
you can't get through them
again dieter does not have a time frame
on when this will be fixed this issue is
only impacting regular ui claimants poor
claimants are not being impacted by this
according to dieter
now some facebook assistant group
administrators suggest to just keep
checking back online
as well for this update to happen of
course we'll update you on that as well